sie waren enge freunde und
geschäftspartner
dann sagte sich rapper bushido im herbst
2017 von manager und klanglos arafat
abou chaker los der war damit nicht
einverstanden
bushido sollte angebliche schulden
zurückzahlen
im streit soll es auch um mehrere
immobilien in berlin gegangen sein
bei zwei treffen in den damaligen
geschäftsräumen des gemeinsamen musik
labels erst guter junge sollen sich
arafat und seine brüder den rapper
bushido heftig vorgenommen haben arafat
soll ihn unter anderem eingeschlossen
mit einer wasserflasche am kopf verletzt
und auch einen stuhl nach dem rapper
geworfen haben
die anklageschrift zählt auf versuchte
räuberische erpressung
freiheitsberaubung gefährliche
körperverletzung nötigung beleidigung
und untreue
einige bekannte rapper könnten im laufe
des verfahrens als zeugen vorgeladen
werden genaues steht noch nicht fest
insgesamt sind 26 verhandlungstage
angesetzt das urteil ist für den 30
november geplant
nun vor dem landgericht in berlin steht
jetzt bild reporterin christine wahl
ziehen sagt uns was genau können wir
jetzt erwarten von diesen prozess vor
allem vom ersten prozesstag in etwa
anderthalb stunden geht hier der prozess
vor dem landgericht in berlin los sich
gegenüberstehen klar dass arafat abou
chaker und rapper bushido arafat abou
chaker ist angeklagt ihm wird unter
anderem so wie wir es auch gerade im
beitrag gehört haben freiheitsberaubung
und schwere körperverletzung vorgeworfen
seitdem bushido sich von seinem
geschäftspartner 2017 getrennt hat steht
der sänger und seine familie unter
polizeischutz
es kam immer wieder zwischen ihm und
arafat abou chaker zu streitereien
dabei ging es immer wieder um geld und
auch um immobilien
jetzt stehen die beiden hier vor dem
landgericht erneut sich gehen
über zum grossen showdown bushido wird
als nebenkläger und als kronzeuge hier
auftreten er wird heute hier auch
persönlich erscheinen
und er wird auch in den nächsten tagen
es soll sogar schon am mittwoch sein
persönlich gegen arafat abou chaker
aussagen
es kann hier ein sehr sehr interessantes
prozess werden und ein sehr besonderer
prozess werden dann erstmals könnten wir
einblicke und die öffentlichkeit könnte
einblicke bekommen
in die machenschaften die geschäfts
machenschaften des abou chaker clans wie
brisant ist denn dann dieser prozess
jetzt vor allem für arafat abou chaker
bisher war es ja immer sehr schwierig
menschen aus diesen klar zu verurteilen
auch den clan chef selber
ja die liste der anklagepunkte ist lang
arafat abou chaker wird unter anderem
vorgeworfen schwere räuberische
erpressung freiheitsberaubung und
gefährliche körperverletzung nötigung
beleidigung und untreue
diese anklagepunkte gehen auf einen fall
aus dem jahr 2018 zurück so hat es
bushido auch den ermittlern erzählt und
zwar gab es damals ein treffen zwischen
bushido und arafat abou chaker arafat
abou chaker soll die bürotür
abgeschlossen haben von innen um dann
anschließend bushido über mehrere
stunden lang beschimpft zu haben und ihn
auch körperlich zu attackieren
wir haben es auch im beitrag gehört es
soll eine plastik wasserflaschen nach
bushido geworfen worden sein
und auch später ein stuhl nach ihm
geworfen worden sein und mit einem stuhl
zugeschlagen haben
ebenfalls in dem raum waren damals ja
und nasser abou chaker das sind zwei
brüder von arafat die sind ebenfalls
hier angeklagt und auch ein dritter
bruder rommel abou chaker ist hier
ebenfalls angeklagt allen dreien wird
mit täterschaft und beihilfe in
einzelnen taten vorgeworfen für die sie
sich jetzt hier auch verantworten müssen
für arafat abou chaker könnte es in dem
fall natürlich auch sehr sehr eng werden
in diesem prozess er ist immer entweder
mit einer geldstrafe davon gekommen in
den vergangenen prozessen gilt nicht
gilt nicht als vorbestraft aber in
diesem fall könnte es wirklich sehr eng
werden für arafat apotheker und christin
sag uns noch wie groß ist die
sicherheitslage jetzt vor ort natürlich
die familie abou chaker ist nicht nur in
berlin bekannt
die sicherheitslage ist sehr hoch das
gericht geht ja auch von einer
besonderen gefährdung aus es gibt
strenge maßnahmen und das strikte
maßnahmen sicherheitsmaßnahmen auch für
die prozessbeobachter die journalisten
mussten sich für wirklich für einen der
wirklich wenigen plätzen im prozess seit
anfang august hier anmelden
die wenigen witze im saal wurden dann
vom gericht hier vergeben
es wird auch eine erhöhte anzahl von
polizisten während des prozesses
anwesend sein
also man sieht auf grund der hohen
sicherheitslage und natürlich auch wegen
corona wurden die plätze im saal massiv
beschränkt auch für die polizei
hierbei handelt es sich natürlich um
einen sehr besonderen gerichtsprozess
und das sieht man hier an der hohen
sicherheitslage